Asalam alaikum.
My name is Quintasa. I'm a 14 years old
junior high school student. I hope to b
>> sister speak in the mic and speak a
little skitwara.
>> Okay.
My name is Suraya. I'm a 14 years old
junior high school student. I have to
bhood among Muslims around the world by
studying Islam abroad through a
scholarship but
>> I'm I'm sorry I can't really understand
you. Can you go slow a little bit?
You're 14year-old after that. What is
your question?
>> Okay. Um I hope to bhood among Muslims
around the world.
>> I I'm sorry I can't understand you.
>> I hope to bail.
>> How to build? Oh yeah, build. Sorry, I'm
sorry.
>> How to build brotherhood?
>> Uh brotherhood among Muslims around the
world by studying Islam abroad through a
scholarship. But in order to do that, I
have to live there without a mahum. Is
this Islam Islamically permissible?
Uh that's my question.
If I heard the question correctly,
sister wants to build the brotherhood
amongst the Muslim Ummah.
For that she wants scholarship.
>> Yes.
>> And she says that can she do without a
maram?
>> Yes.
>> Sister, the requirement for me is that
if you are traveling, you require a
meam. Correct?
>> Yes.
>> So you want to build the brotherhood of
the Muslim Ummah.
>> Yes.
>> Where? All over the world.
>> So you want to travel all over the
world. Yes.
>> So if you have to travel all over the
world, do you have to travel to build
the brotherhood?
>> No. But I mean
>> if you want to travel, you love
traveling. I love traveling. Then you
require a
you require a that's a that's a
requirement. Traveling is good. Quran
says look at the various signs of Allah.
Travel in the earth of Allah. But for
that as a lady you when you when you
travel if you cross more than 87
kilometers you have to require a meam to
travel that's a requirement for the
protection of the woman. So your meam
can be your father can be your brother
and when you get married it can be your
husband. So you can ask your father if
he wants to travel with you. Ask your
brother if he wants to travel with you
or maybe once you get married your
husband wants to you can put that
condition. I'll only marry you if you
take me around different parts of the
world. Whether the condition right or
wrong that different
>> but uh the condition of application the
scholarship is families of students must
live outside of uh the country I want to
study.
>> Oh you want to take scholarship from
outside?
>> Yes.
>> Ah scholarship from outside.
>> So then you travel. So when you take
scholarship while traveling take your
father once you're in the lady's host no
problem.
>> Okay.
>> So the requirement is that for traveling
you require a maham
and then when you're staying if the stay
is safe
like you have to go from here to
Jakarta. Yes
>> or you have to far away.
So you require a mamm to travel. One
sister is there if the atmosphere is
secured it is safe for the woman and
she's staying in woman environment hijab
is maintained no problem do you
understand
>> I understand
>> but while traveling you require a maram
>> okay
>> hope that answers the question but but
but if you want to travel is that travel
beneficial is important some people want
to do medicine engineering why to become
engineer and they study outside what is
the benefit so what you are studying
should be beneficial for your dean
Yes.
>> Okay. Thank you.